good afternoon everyone thank you for
coming out on such short notice
i'm assistant sheriff chris jones
and i'm here to give you a few details
on last night's officer-involved
shooting
before i get into those details i want
to give you a brief update
on our officer who was shot last night
sheriff lombardo briefed last night
referenced our officer who was shot
while serving this community
that officer is identified as 29 year
old
shea michelanas
officer michelanis has been with lvmpd
for four years
and is assigned to the convention center
area command
his condition remains unchanged from
last night
he is still in grave condition on life
support
our thoughts and prayers are with him
and his family
and we ask that yours be as well
reference the officer involved shooting
ordinarily we do not
brief on officer-involved shootings
until 72 hours later
however we're not in ordinary
times we felt it was important to come
to you today
and give you a few details of the event
last night just after 11 pm a large
crowd had formed near the 300 block of
las vegas boulevard south
this is right next to
the federal courthouse on las vegas
boulevard
individuals within the crowd were
becoming rowdy
and an order to disperse was given by
officers
shortly afterwards the majority of the
crowd dispersed
traveling southbound on las vegas
boulevard
a few individuals did remain
one of those individuals has been
identified as george
jorge gomez
he's a 25 year old hispanic male 180
pounds
mr gomez was armed with two glock
pistols
and a third glock pistol that was
inserted into
a carbine conversion kit
mr gomez began to walk toward officers
who were staged on the steps of the
federal courthouse
clearly ignoring the order to disperse
one metro officer in gate observed mr
gomez and approached
and fired several rounds from a low
lethal shotgun
this caused mr gomez to turn northbound
toward the other officers who were
trying to get to our downed officer
those officers were threatened by mr
gomez as he raised his firearm toward
them
and they engaged him
firing several rounds and striking him
mr gomez was transported to an area
hospital where he was pronounced
deceased
we will have our normal 72-hour brief
with more information
but again we felt it was necessary given
the times that we're in to come to the
community
and give them information about this
event
we'll show a couple of videos
from last night and then i'll take a few
questions
this is mr gomez
i'll take a couple of questions before i
turn it over to deputy chiefs jim
siebach was mr gomez with anybody there
at this point we believe he was alone
yes do we know mr gomez is a nevada
resident or a las vegas resident he is
in nevada las vegas nevada resident yes
are you prepared for more demonstrations
if they occur uh you know councilman
several dancing called for a curfew and
the call for the national guard
could you comment is metro prepare to
hold more or monitor more demonstrations
or
are you prepare for a curfew we fully
anticipate more demonstrations
we fully anticipate more protests
deputy chief jim siebach will get into
the details of that in our preparation
for that so the answer to your question
short is yes but he'll get into more
details
yes sir in terms of uh calling in either
military or more national guard whose
call is that in the city in las vegas
and that it is a little bit unusual and
that we have city county the way metro
operates whose decision is that is that
something you guys are considering right
now right that decision has been made we
will have national guardsmen with us
tonight
and again chief seaback will get into
that if there are no further questions
specifically about the officer-involved
shooting i'll turn it over to deputy
chief jim siebach thank you
just one on that one um i just wanted to
be clear these are two incidents
that were connected to each other
two completely separate instances not
related
thank you and good afternoon my name is
deputy chief jim siebach
i'm one of the two patrol deputy chiefs
over our patrol division
i've worked these protests since they
started this past
several days
let me first convey
thanks to those in the community our
first responder partners and all those
that have reached out to us
to show support for us and the families
of our
injured officer
your thoughts and prayers are much
appreciated
i also want to say that what we're
seeing is not indicative of the
community i've policed over the last 27
years nor does it look like the
community that we all know and love and
what we're seeing is not representative
of what we all know las vegas to be
i also want to reiterate as sheriff
lombardo has said from the beginning
that these events that sparked these
protests are inconsistent
with the training and protocols of the
lvmpd
we are also sickened by what we saw that
sparked all of this as an agency and
from the patrol division
we respect everyone's constitutional
right to protest we are here to support
you
and to keep you safe as long as it's
done lawfully
unfortunately that isn't what we've been
seeing
what we as an agency are consistently
seeing over these last few days
is that these protests
these protests start out peacefully
with all the good intentions for
significant change to spark the
conversation
and
hear what people ex allow people to
express what they want to say
but as the night goes on the good
intended and law-abiding people leave
and those that seek to break the law
stay behind these people are clearly
not here for peaceful purposes
they are set on damaging our community
our businesses and to cause harm to our
officers and the people in the area
i watched firsthand from the streets
from our command post how these
criminals are trying to leverage these
peaceful demonstrations to their
advantage
over the few days we're seeing these
offenders become increasingly more
aggressive
we're seeing them armed with bats with
axes with glass cutters so they can
cause damage to structures
we see them vandalize and throw bottles
and rocks and damaging objects in order
to cause harm
and the rocks that they're throwing
they're not the kind that you would skip
across a lake
instead these are the chunks of asphalt
chunks of cinder block that cause
significant damage or harm once they're
hurt once they're thrown and hit their
target
we've had over 25 officers injured
from these types of objects the last
several days
i'm going to ask them to play a few
clips that we've captured these are just
small representations of what we've been
seeing
as you can see you can uh go and play
the video
i got that
hurry up
oh [ __ ]
they're shooting motors above people now
at the cops
is logic shots up on
oh what's up dude what's up a bunch of
people on the strat we're saying we're
right next to you what's up man
yeah what's up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
yes
we're fine
[Music]
they've got it underwrapped so far
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
those are some of the examples of what
my officers are trying to
contain
bring to a peaceful resolution and when
they're committing crimes like that
we will be taking them to jail we have
been taken in the jail
as their aggression changes
our resolve only becomes that much more
clear
we are simply not going to tolerate this
kind of unlawful behavior
we will arrest you and you will go to
jail and lastly i want to remind all of
those that seek to lawfully protest to
make change in our community
please reach out to us
meet with us
sheriff lombardo has demonstrated the
willingness to always work with our
community he has provided transparency
and all we do
we listen to our community
our use of force policy was created in
conjunction with community members
we recently trained all of our
department on the new policy that
included way before these incidents that
happen that includes putting people in a
recovery position as soon as possible
after an arrest
the goal of lvmpd is to continue to grow
and partner with our community
finally i just ask for the public to
please continue to pray for our officer
and all that is going on in our
community
thank you
is there any indication these groups are
well organized or i've heard reports of
other cities possibly having out of
state instigators or have you identified
any of that i don't have enough
information to answer that the
information that i have seen is the
majority are still local
yes
we've been down on the street there are
obviously thousands of officers down
there
around the subway someone breaks into
your house you call 9-1-1 who comes
right now
we still have officers policing our
community keeping us safe we've been
bringing in officers extra on overtime
we've had great partnerships with
henderson and north las vegas city
marshals night county nhp uh parole and
probation all of our partners are coming
together to keep southern nevada safe
i know we're coming up on the sixth year
since officer
soldo and officer beck were slain how
heavy does this weigh on the department
this impacts all of our officers but it
also reminds our it reminds everyone of
the dangers of our job
it reminds everyone that the commitment
that these officers these men and women
take every day to serve our community
and it does strengthen their resolve to
want to do the best that they can and we
have tremendous leadership here at this
department that continues to provide the
support
the
wellness services to our officers and to
their families and we are checking the
pulse of the morale every single day to
make sure our officers are ready and
prepared before they hit the streets
sir how do you differentiate between
those people who are there for good
intentions and those people who are not
we allowed these protests to occur we
allow them to stay lawfully on the
sidewalks sometimes when it gets too big
they have to go onto the streets
last night for example
we made room for them we tried to block
traffic
we even moved officers back away so the
protesters could go through but a
contingent remained behind as i said
last night the crowd was probably around
three thousand uh and the majority of
them started marching peacefully back
but a good number and say approximately
three to five hundred stayed behind and
then they begin to
do actions such as you saw there
yes
how do you find that balance between
there's been a lot of talk about
bringing in people with riot gear stuff
like that how it could potentially
escalate situations more national guard
how do you find a balance between
escalating the situation and then also
showing a sign of authority like we're
seeing up in minneapolis for example
what i'll speak to here locally is we
did provide our officers with
protective equipment because of the
items that were being thrown if you
notice on the first day a lot of our
officers were not wearing that gear and
we did have a lot of officers injured
and so again
we give the people the opportunity to
do their
constitution constitutionally protected
activity lawfully and when they're not
we provide them an opportunity to stop
we give them a dispersal order and we
ask them to move on and if not then we
have to take the appropriate action
yes in the back
now we know these people have paragons
they'll probably change their strategy
with when you go to these places
and
have some with these people i'm sorry i
didn't hear the first part of your
question
well now we know these people have
partners right so you will change your
strategy when you go to these places
and confront these people
uh our officer safety uh is always at
the utmost uh every day we try to learn
lessons learned from the night before on
the different tactics that are being
employed and we try to do uh
different tactics in response to keep
our officers safe the community safe and
so we can have a peaceful night
regarding the
george jorge gomez did he have any
priors did he have any other
interactions with law enforcement that
were negative very few uh just one prior
of
one narcotics prior so thank you again
for coming out we'll have more
information for you in the coming days
thank you